hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled realize better NGS
results through gentle cell sorting i am
michelle ashton of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roads and brought to you by Milton e
biotech to learn more about our sponsors
please visit www.sap.com/learnbi for our
and anytime you want during the
presentations to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window will report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speakers we win a graduate student
researcher at the University of
California Irvine School of Medicine and
Felix Adler the global product manager
of cell sorting at Milton E biotech for
a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen korean felix you may
now begin your presentation thank you
very much for the kind introduction
Michelle
my name is Felix eppela I'm the global
product manager for the Mexican title
cell sorter at multi biotech and today
we would like to talk about how gentle
cell sorting can lead to very solid and
good results in NGS or single cell
genomic analysis our talk will be
divided into two parts the second part
will be presented by cui he will talk
about his research on neuron memory
epithelial cells and how he utilizes
single-cell RNA sequencing technologies
as well as cell sorting technologies in
order to gain a maximum out of this
experiment in the beginning I would like
to give a short introduction on gentle
cell sorting upstream of next-generation
sequencing analysis and of course I
would like to focus on the max quantizer
by doing so so let's first have a look
on NGS or single-cell genomics
application areas in general as you all
know these both technologies are really
really important and are utilized in
lots of different application areas
starting from basic research in for
example cell biology immunology or
developmental biology but also going
into translational or clinical fields
such as cell therapy cancer research
metabolic disorders or in the moment
very important also the research on
infectious diseases at Milton E biotech
we are actually focused on providing
products which allow for a very gentle
and proper
sample preparation upstream of NGS and
single-cell genomics analysis I would
like to shortly highlight the gentle max
associators which can be utilized if you
start with solid tissues such as sprain
for example or tumors and want to
generate a single cell suspension and
also coming from blood products we have
several interesting products for
straining and clearing coming to a next
step an optional step that is of course
only important if you are interested in
specific target cells and that is the
cell isolation or cell sorting cell
isolation via our max technology and so
via magnetic beads can be utilized here
we have an example for tumor
infiltrating leukocytes which has been
enriched based on their expression of
cd4 t sites if you are interested in
multi parameter analysis or sorting of
the cells
flow cytometry is a very good way to go
and here we offer the max quantizer cell
sorter in order to sort your cells based
on multiple parameters on a very gentle
way so you get out very viable cells and
very high purity x' as you can see in
that example given for the natural
killer cells
coming from those technologies then to
your downstream analysis you can proceed
with your NGS or single-cell genomics
analysis and today we of course would
like to focus on the Mexican titles of
the cell sorting step prior to MGS or
single-cell genomics so why is it in
general important to sort yourself prior
to these analysis of course the very
obvious reason is you're interested in
enriching a specific target cell
population and thereby to improve your
reads this can be done based on
expression of specific markers on the
cells but also based on their size or
granularity another important sector Y
cell sorting should be applied upstream
of single-cell genomics analysis is the
exclusion of dead cells and the removal
of debris both can actually contribute
to a high background by extraneous DNA
or RNA contaminations for example and
thereby leads to high costs so you can
actually decrease your cost by sorting
yourself upstream of your very expensive
single-cell genomic analysis but cell
sorting also can come with some
associated problems first
lots of the cell's orders which are
currently available in the market has a
very harsh sorting procedure the so
called droplet sales orders these can
depend on your cells of interest again
leads to dead cells and those dead cells
might end up in your precious sample and
if you are only analyzing let's say
10,000 cells in the end if you have 60%
viability only you have already 40% of
dead cells in and this also leads to
very high costs in the end and of course
DNA and RNA contamination can also here
leads to high backgrounds or false
results the second problem is that due
to the stressful sorting gene expression
artifacts can be generated and
and might also lead to false results
specifically if you're interested in
markers around stress activation or
metabolics for example and another
important sector to consider is timely
delays a very yeah difficult and slow
processing might also then again lead to
gene expression alterations in your
target cell and that again to false
results so it is all about circumventing
and these problems and we think we have
a very nice solution with a maximum
title cell sorter so I would like to
introduce to you the instrument itself
the title as you can see here is a
benchtop cell sorter with a very small
footprint it comes with two different
screens and very important factors
actually that you can control the
sorting temperature between four and
twenty five degrees of cell deals I said
before we can sort our cells based on
multiple parameters up to ten in the
Mexican title the instrument comes to
three different lasers and you can sort
based on up to eight fluorescence
channels and two scattered channels
which provide full experimental
flexibility and a possibility of multi
parameter sorting unfortunately due to
time reasons I cannot go into too much
details concerning the specifications of
the instrument but if you are interested
please visit our website there you can
find our image progr
or the user manual which contains all
the necessary information or you are
always welcome to contact us you can see
the maximum title cartridge where all
the sorting happens so the cells won't
leave this cartridge during the sorting
process we divided three different
chambers in this cartridge on the left
hand side we have the input chamber
where your cell suspension of interests
are filled in in the middle we have a
positive collection chamber where the
positively collected cells will end up
and on the right hand side we have
the negative collection chamber where
all the rest will flow through it is
important to mention that we don't have
any ways so you can always regain
yourself from the negative collection
chamber and run them again through
another cartridge if you want to sort
another population out of your sample a
mixing propeller in the input chamber
prevents the cells from settling down
where all the analysis and the sorting
actually takes place is the microchip at
the bottom of the cartridge and on the
right hand side of the slide you can see
on the bottom view and in a zoom the
microchip itself I would like to show
you this comparison here to make you
wear like how small the microchip really
is and if we zoom in we see that there's
actually some channels inside this
microchip so if the if the cells come
from the input chamber and onto the
microchip they enter this on the lower
left-hand side and they run through the
sorting channel where they also pass the
lasers they're analyzed and in a paid in
a case of a positive event the magnetic
pulse opens a microwave which then
simply redirects the cell into the upper
channel so the cell ends up in the
positive collection chamber we can have
a look on that specific love you can see
it here so in this position the valve
actually is closed all the sample flows
through into the negative collection
chamber now if a magnetic pulse is
induced the valve will open and very
gently redirect the cell so it ends up
in the positive collection chamber to
get a better understanding like how this
process really is working I would like
to show you a short video on that so you
can really understand like where the
cells are redirected and how to flow
through the microchip
you
so now that you have seen the
animation and also the video of the very
very fast micro world and opening and
closing cycle only takes around 30
microseconds so the microwave can move
up to 30,000 times per second it became
quite obvious that this is a very very
different cell sorting technology if you
compare it to the classical fax the
fluorescence activated cell sorting
droplets orders you can see a picture
describing the technology here on the
right hand side on the slide and this
technology comes with some problems
first of all droplets orders are always
open systems so the aerosols and
droplets which are produced are in an
open space and which of course is a
problem if you are for example
interested in going into clinical
applications but which can also be a
problem for example in terms of
contamination contamination and sample2
sample carryover can also derive from
fluidics and tubing's which are shared
between the samples and which are inside
the instrument so the sample has to flow
through the instrument in order to be
sorted another problem coming with this
kind of technology is the very hard
sorting process so the sorting takes
place at very high pressures and these
systems which depending on the nozzle
size can go up to 70 psi and these are
followed by a very strong decompression
once the droplets including the cells
leave the models
directly after that a charge is applied
to the cell in order to redirect the
droplets in an electric field and this
is also another stressful event for the
cell and in addition strong shear forces
act on the cells during the sorting
process and all of that can in the end
lead to very high cellular stress levels
low viability and death cells also a low
final cell yield bad functionalities in
the cells but also to the generation of
artifact now if you compare with a cell
sorting technology and the maximum title
which is microvalves mediated we have a
very gentle cell sorting technology here
acting on a very low pressure of only
1.5 to 2 psi
there is no decompression and no charge
applied to the cells and only mightier
forces acting on the cells and this
results in highly viable and functional
cells after the sorting process but also
the system is very safe and that is due
to its close and sterile cartridge
environment there is no carryover from
sample to sample as the cells won't
leave the cartridge during the sorting
process there are no critics inside the
system and so no contaminations can come
from the instrument into the cartridge
but also for the operator is a very safe
cell sorting system on one hand as I
said it closed but it's also not
producing activity any aerosols and this
might come in come in very handy if
you're sorting infectious materials such
as virus infected cell for example so
all in all we have a very gentle way to
sort cells using the mark on title and
on the next slide I would like to show
you a setup we actually built in order
to film the cells which are actually
arriving in the positive collection
chamber and therefore we we put an
endoscope inside the positive collection
chamber and you can see in a video which
I will show shortly
see how the cells flow into the positive
collection chamber chamber in a very
very gentle way but I'm also showing
this video to make another point here
and that is that the cells are actually
strongly concentrated during the sorting
process because the valve only opens in
that moment where the specific target
cell is at the valve and then directing
soldiers again
meaning the main portion of the buffer
will flow into the negative collection
chamber and depending on your downstream
ya process for example how you perform
your library prep if you for example
work with a 10x chromium this might be
interesting because it could potentially
save you a step of centrifugation
you
I would also like to shortly comment on
the workflow we see in the we apply in
the microphone title and of course it is
a flow cytometry based cell sorter with
up to 10 parameters so this means of
course we have yeah you have to think
about your gating strategy and the
antibody panel you want to use but once
you setup your experiment you can save
the workspace and then the workflow is
very very easy and straightforward and
that is simply you have to load the
sample into the cartridge you scan the
cartridge which has a barcode and so all
the settings are already set directly in
the software you load the cartridge into
the temperature controlled loading
chamber and then you just press play and
can walk away it's an operator free
sorting process you don't have to stay
in front of the instrument and check for
example for drop delay or something like
that because this is simply not needed
in the title sorting system once the
cells haven't saw that you can come back
collect your sort itself and proceed
with your experiment and in a direct
comparison this can lead to a hands-on
time which is up to nine times less
compared to a conventional droplet
sorter and with that I come to the last
part of my introduction and that is I
would like to give you some application
examples before cui talks about his
research just to discuss again how
gentle the cell sorting process on the
microphone title really is and with this
first example I would like to discuss
the sorting of neutrophils and everyone
who already worked with beautiful
granulocytes knows that these cells are
really really sensitive really fragile
they can be easily activated they will
also die very easily so you have to be
very careful with handling them now you
can either input and the sort we were
able to sort the neutrophils to a high
purity of 98% but very important the
cells also stayed viable after
dot 98% viability which is already great
but doesn't necessarily tell us like if
the cells are still functional or might
have been activated so we check the
surface expression levels of some
proteins which are either up or down
regulated during interval activation and
as you can see the samples in the mark
on title which is the orange bar are
comparable to the one of the negative
control which is the white bar but also
functionality of these cells was still
fully intact so we checked for example
for phagocytosis or the my Croatian
towards the chemo kind gradient also
called chemotaxis in this case MLP
gradient both very complex processes a
lot of signal transduction is involved
and mechanical interactions of proteins
and as you can see both are still
working very well and this proof that
also these cells have been sorted using
the maximum title as the float that
Tommy to bed cell so that they were
still fully functional and not activated
after the sorting process a second
example I would like to discuss is about
sorting of IPC derived dopaminergic
progenitors and this data was kindly
provided by the Zuka droid from the
saira Institute in Kyoto Japan and is
actually deriving from a clinical study
they are currently running in order to
treat a patient suffering from
Parkinson's disease and they were first
working with a fact droplets order but
encountered some difficulties in
translating into the clinics with the
title this was much more easier because
of the clothes and sterile sorting
environment we also offer our
consumables and a GMP compliant format
so that was already great for them but
they also wanted to check the gentle
aspect of the cell sorting because they
had some problems with the expansion and
the yield of their cells after the
sorting process
what you can see here is an analysis 30
days after these IP CD rice dopaminergic
progenitors have been sorted and you can
see these cells are forming spheres and
the spheres in the max quantizer for
example are much bigger and this is
highly significant and come sent in hand
with a much higher cell yield of 160
percent compared to the other sample and
actually is due to yeah very functional
viable cells and so we have a high cell
proliferation and expansion possible in
the micron title but it's not only about
cell growth so of course about
engraftment of the cells and you can
also test this in vitro by checking the
area of new ripe extensions which are
actually an indicator of cross provider
capacity of these cells and again you
can tell by eye that this area is bigger
in the Mexican title sorted samples if
you compare to the facts triplet sorter
and of course this goes hand-in-hand
with a higher cross survival capacity
which is of course key for a successful
cellular therapy and that is also why
the group now uses the title in its
clinical trial the first in human iPS
sea based clinical trial to treat
patients suffering from Parkinson's
disease and if you are interested in
more detail from that we can also
provide a poster which had been
presented by the zoo Godoy at the ISS CR
in 2019 and this brings me to the last
slide of the introduction and it is just
that I would like to mention that using
the Mexican title you cannot only sort
normal variant cells you also can sort
other stuff we frequently thought for
example bacteria or yeast but you can
also sort
nuclei which is of course very
interesting for applications in the NGS
and single-cell genomics context and
here I want to like you wanted to show
you an
you can see the input and the respective
sort fracture we were able to enrich the
nuclei based on their staining on top II
and marker I can not actually talk about
because the data we also got from
customer and it's confidential but you
can see in general we were able to and
rich is nuclei to high purity and with
that being said I think it's time to
hand over to qui so we can learn more
about his reasons and how he utilized
gentle cell sorting technologies in his
workflow and yeah with that qui I'd like
to hand over to you and I'm looking
forward to listen to your presentation
thank you very much
Thank You Felix um okay so welcome I am
I'm Queen when I'm in dr. Kai Katzenberg
lab at the University of California
Irvine and we work on profiling the
normal breast development and how that
leads to or how the development of
breast cancer is initiated mainly in
human we've also done a lot of work in
Mouse and today we'll talk a little bit
about our efforts in that so a little
bit of background on why we do what we
do
so with the memory so today I'm going to
talk about the now system and with the
mammary gland development in mice at the
very top panel this is taken from a
review you can see that it's mainly a
fat pad that epithelial cells grow into
almost like a tree structure and with
that you can see that the main cells
that make up or the cells of interest to
us are the epithelial cells and that is
because those epithelial cells are
believed to be the cells of interest
that's out initiating cells for a breast
cancer and as you can see the bottom
panel there's a lot of supporting cells
within the mammary gland there are
adipocyte there are other stromal cells
such as fibroblasts there are new cell
macrophage t-cell b-cell they're mast
cells red blood cell all different kind
of cell types in there and if we really
want to study just epithelial cells what
we have to do is enriched for these
cells somehow and now continue to
profile them
so in a previous publish recently
published paper it's shown that there
are three major style type within the
epithelial
system or the epithelial cells and you
can see there's one basal population and
two luminal cell types and within that
there are multiple cell states so what
we want to do is be able to reconstruct
this within the mouse system
and to give you guys a little bit of
background on our approach before and
what we're currently testing is what we
would do is extract out the mammary
gland from these mice mechanically
dissociate them down to almost a single
cell pretty much a single cell
suspension and what we would do is fax
isolate these cells for epithelial cells
before and run them under 10x but we
were interested in seeing is is there
another approach to reduce the stress
that fax induce on the cell so what it
did in this test was take the same cell
suspension split it into two pool one
where we ran onto the fax machine and
the other we ran on the title machine
for sorting and then we ran both example
on to the 10x right afterwards just to
see the profile
so why would we want to take the
single-cell approach for this as you can
see on the left when of the previous
work that has been done using Brook bulk
approach you can see where it's just
you're just taking a sample of an
average sample so you can't really tell
Harrison maybe at the South State or
type level where when we do it on the
single-cell level as you can see on the
right there you can tell which cells are
high for which gene which cells are low
and be able to distinguish on the
single-cell level which cells are of
interest and which cell are not instead
of just pulling them all together and
taking an average of everything so the
sequencing approach that we take is the
10x genomics approach with using various
RNAi 3-prime sequencing platform and
what that does is it takes in a single
cell suspension it generates droplet it
partitioned these cells with barcode
into droplet for us to be able to
generate a cDNA library that you need
that's barcode unique for each cell for
us to later be able to by automatically
distinguish which transcript came from
which cells as you can see with the 10x
approach where it's partitioning cells
into this droplet it's very important
for you to start off with a very clean
sample that are single cell if they're
not single cell you're going to get
multiple if they're sticking together
you're going to get a multi-bit droplet
and that would throw off your data or if
there's a lot of ambient RNA that's put
into this platform that would also be
captured and you can't it's very hard to
tell what's ambient are what was ambient
RNA and what came from the cell so to
show you guys the importance so these
are two samples that were acquired one
on the left was not sorted and one on
the right was sorted and you can see
this is an output from cell Ranger but
it shows cell calling and the sample
that was not sorted have very high
contaminating
ambient RNA and you can see it reads it
takes about it only about 50% of the
sequence read were actually used or
called in within the cell while the
sordid cells had about 97 98 percent of
the reads and cell so with an unsorted
sample you're wasting about half of your
reads your sequencing read at the same
time it makes it very hard for the
program to tell which are thousand which
are just empty droplet containing
ambient RNA and in addition to that all
of your droplet that contains actual
cell also contain ambient RNA it's sort
of clout every your real readout so this
has been shown before buck over it again
with our set up what we did was we did
this in triplicate and with the fax
order we use two different fax machine
just to see if it's reproducible and the
PSI that we use a hundred micron nozzle
and that produces or puts the cell under
around 20 to 25 psi of pressure and
while the fax sort itself when we ran it
through the cartridge source around 1.5
psi so there's a big difference and in
addition to the fax their cells being
compressed with about 20 psi is the
rapid decompression as it comes out of
the nozzle to be collected into the
collection tube
so this is the overall data with all six
sample so three replicates or three for
facts and three for title we collected
around almost 48,000 memory epithelial
cell from the mice and you can see what
we reproduced as shown before and human
are the three major cell types o1 basil
and two luminal population and you can
see on the right there the top 10
markers even map for each of these cell
type or you can see that they between
the facts or that cell and the title
sorted cell have very similar to capture
so we're not losing too many important
cells for either of these method
so to go into a little bit more finer
detail analysis what I did was I subset
it on individual cell types of Basel
luminal one boom 102 and did a
comparison for their marker gene and as
you can see on the right there
there isn't too big of a difference
there isn't actually any difference
between the facts and titles sort itself
or that marker gene so we're able to
pick up traditionally what we would in
fact as we do in title and on the left
there is a Disney plot colored by the
replicate so you can see that the three
replicas for our experiment overlaps
very well and this is the cluster
without any batch correction so we can
see that we're not introducing anything
major with title so that cell or fact
sort itself
but the difference you can see really
comes down to when you take a look at
the content of these cells or sort of
what they're expressing so when we take
a look at numbers of gene capture um I
percent Mitel you can see that's where
it stands out a little bit more with the
facts sorted selves we capture
definitely more gene so it's around
1,400 cells for title sorted those are
1,400 genes for title sorted cell and
around 1200 gene for facts or themselves
and when you move over to the UM I so
the unique molecular identifier the malt
molecule we do capture more with title
cells around 3200 um eyes for title and
around 2400 for facts and 4 percent my
toe it is a little bit higher in title
and we believe that could be due to just
well when we run the 10x sequencing
we're capturing more gene we're
capturing more transcript hence why
we're catching a little bit more of the
percent my toe
more of those mitochondrial genes
so there was a paper that was published
where they take a look at sort of a
dissociation and do signature in there
sort of protocol and sort of see is
their signature and it's that
reproducible so what I did was I took a
look at that signature and scored that
on our data set just to see is it higher
in the title is higher in the facts or
is it similar and when we take a look at
those gene we can see that the facts are
that cell has slightly higher expression
of these genes compared to title and
that was one set of team so what I
wanted to do was went online acquired
sets of genes that are involved in
multiple pathways such as apoptosis the
necrosis etapa G cell death everything
else that you see here and what you can
see is that when I scored these pathways
deceptive genes for self that were
sorted on the title machine ourselves
they were sorted out of fax machine you
can see that fax or that cell have
slightly higher expression of these are
score excite ly higher for these pathway
and for a majority of these pathway so
that was very interesting what we wanted
that was just sort of on the gene
expression level what we wanted to see
was does that carry over
is there something functionally
different with these cells so taking
those same exact cells actually that
were dissociated split sort on the fax
machine Tyler machine we took those same
exact cells after running it on the tena
or Tim pool of cell after running on the
10x we split off some and we the CDP
cells in major gel to run a memo stria
formation assay to see do we get more
sphere do we get larger sphere of is
their growth difference from this
long-term and you can see here on the
left is quick illustration and actual
image from our memo sphere after seven
days you can see
that title sorted sphere on the image on
the left there has there's more sphere
compared to the facts or its cells on
the right and bar graph on the right
there is a quantification for the four
experiment and overall you can see that
long-term experiment you can see that
title cells have much more sphere growth
compared to the facts sorted cells
so a quick summary for everyone so with
our data set our experiment we detect
the pre-major style type as previously
civilian human and what's very nice is
that we see a similar cell type between
facts and title so with facts were not
losing any important cell type but we're
not gaining anything too much with
either one but what's interesting
especially for next generation or the
single cell experiment is that with
Kaito Soviet isolated cells we actually
see higher teen and you will my capture
for these cells while with the facts
isolated cells therein to do they're
introduced with more stress throughout
the entire process so we we do see a
slight in induction of these stress
response gene and functionally what's
very interesting is we see that title
sort itself form more mammal sphere and
that's very important for a long-term
experiment or if these cells are of
interest and you need them to grow up so
thank you
we'll take any question
Thank You plea and Felix for your
informative presentations we can now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you might ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay this
first question is for you Felix how many
cells can be loaded into a title
cartridge and how fast can they be
sorted hi those it's a very interesting
question so the maximum cel amount we
actually describe for the microphone
title average is like 50 million cells
per milliliter and you can load up to
ten milliliters into one cartridge which
makes 500 million cells per total
cartridge that is of course the upper
maximum we state and the whole system
runs with four visitors per hour soon we
will have a second cartridge type which
will allow sorting with eight
milliliters per hour at the same maximum
cell density so cells can run with
55,000 per second through the system and
in the new cartridge type was up to
110,000 per second the maximum sought
rate which really in the end makes sense
is around probably six six thousand per
second
thanks Felix this one is also for you
can you also combine cell sorting on the
max quant title with cell isolation via
magnetic feeds
yes actually you can do so and we have
also several customers research as well
as clinical which are combining either
for some of the auto max Pro and title
or in cleaning max prodigy and the title
and it often makes sense if you have
started with yeah I don't know very big
amount of cells like Luca Peck for
example so you can do a deep balloting
step on the max based technologies and
then to pick your yeah special target
populations of interest maybe also based
on multiple parameters and you want to
sort them to high purity you can go then
afterwards into the title so yes they
are compatible
we why do you think the title sorted
samples contain a higher amount of
captured genes and um I that's a very
good question so when we initially run
with facts we I realized you know
running through all the food expression
decompression all of this pressure
change really you know has to have some
sort of effect on ourselves and we
believe that it probably mainly due to
that that's why you see lower capture in
facts so that cells where these cells
are being squeezed and there let go
through all of these change in pressure
and what I would like to remind everyone
is that our epithelial cells are fairly
robust they you know handle facts they
can sit around for a little bit longer
but we've worked a lot with also like
Felix mentioned before nuclei and
neutrophil where the cell type or a
little bit or the whatever you're
sorting through especially nuclei are a
lot more sensitive we do see a lot of
loss and gene capture when we run them
through fax and that's probably due to
the change in pressure same same thing
where there are multiple research where
they have shown their harsh pipetting or
anything along that line so sheer force
with the really reduced our viability
and also gene content and with the title
system we're sort of just flowing these
cells through a chamber with very low
psi so low shear force are really no
change in pressure you're preserving
that cells and its content a lot better
right thank you okay Felix this one is
for you what if the samples and interest
are really dirty and contain a lot of
debris can you still sort this on tight
oh yes okay this is a very good question
as well so of course those kind of
samples are much more demanding and one
should consider maybe also having some
extra steps in the sample preparation
prior to going into the microphone tight
or any sorting system which could be for
example of cycle gradient centrifugation
or also for example isolation by our Mac
speeds before you go there but in
general before we fill our sample into
the microphone title cartridge we go
through a pre separation filter of 20
micrometer mesh size and inside the
input chamber before the cells flow onto
the micro chip we have an extra three
dimensional filter system implemented
also to prevent yeah debris or I don't
know free DNA aggregations or something
like that from getting into the sorting
channel and clogging it order the
microbots
so in general yes you can do so but
depending on how dirty your sample is
you should consider implementing some
extra sample preparation steps
now do you need a biosafety cabinet to
run title with infectious materials
yeah that's a that's a very interesting
question of course also during these
specific times currently so what we
really have here is a cell sorting
instrument which is not producing any
aerosols or droplets to flee as droplets
base cells or resume and it's inside a
closed cartridge system so that is a
very high level of safety already of
course we have an opening and closing
and that is through an 0.1 micrometer
sterile filter we just pump in air which
then presses the liquid through the
microchip and in the positive or
negative collection chambers this air
has actually to get out of the cottage
again through 0.1 micrometer sterile
filters which are actually also
hydrophobic from the inside so it is
very unlikely depending on what you're
sorting that anything gets out because
no aerosols are produced and we are in a
quite closed system with very very small
openings which are in additional
hydrophobic but of course this is yeah
depending on the material you're going
to sort and also depending on the risk
assessment of our customers so there's
no definite answer to that but what we
for sure can say is that we have an
increased level of safety
due to the absence of aerosols and a
closed system
thank you okay Cleve this is a
three-part question so let me know if
you need to repeat it how much time was
passing between the sorting step and a
library prep using 10x and do you expect
the stress response even to increase
after more time has passed now might
this be connected to the lack of
manosphere formation using conventional
facts boarding okay so the first
question how much time was passed
between sorting at the library prep and
when this experiment was originally ran
we wanted to move as fast as possible to
be able to preserve any prevent any gene
changes and preserve its native state as
much as possible so it was pretty much
about 30 minutes from the facts or title
machine onto the 10x for RT and I guess
the second question is do you expect the
stress response student to increase in
any way if there was I guess more time
to relapse and definitely we can see
that you know what cells were to sit
there they will change hence why than
everyone anyone who works on single cell
sequencing or anything that's very
sensitive along that line they want to
move as fast as possible and to
introduce as little change as possible
and running these cells either on the
fax machine on the title machine does
introduce a little bit of stress and I
believe that if the cells were to sit
there for a little bit longer those
stress response we'll have time to
actually be able to kick in and increase
and actually we'll see a greater
difference see I guess especially
important for those two either can't get
their cells on to the sort of the
sequencer as fast as possible or those
who have long term experiment I guess
that comes to the third part with the
NamUs fear if this is tied in any way
with the memo's fear information and it
looks like there it definitely does
where we see that cell setters ran
through so that the dis dition was sorta
with the
isolation you can see that a lot of the
gene which is lost during that process
so recovery for these cells might be a
little bit longer and I guess depending
on cell type recovery it might not ever
be possible so with our nameless
reformation assay we can see that
potentially a lot of these cells that
the potentially formed EMA sphere either
die off or it takes them longer to
recover and to form nanos fear that's
why about after seven days we see a lot
more hemisphere with the title sort
itself
thanks so much it looks like we have
time for one more question
this one's for you Felix is enrichment
of rare cells for example 0.1 present
percent target frequency possible as
well that's actually quite short answer
yes it is so you can easily go and yeah
in a quite straightforward a one-step
sort already to quite high purity easily
over 95 or % or even higher you can also
actually implement like a debugging
sorting step first on title to get to
higher purities and then with a second
step for example to very high purity as
well so that depends a little bit on the
sample we have several customers working
with for example MSC's or t-rex coming
from primary materials which has very
very low frequencies so yes this is
possible
great thank you Klee and Felix do either
if you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
so maybe from my side and if you are
interested of course in the Mexican
title cell sorting technology you can
always contact us at milky biotech can
contact your local sales representative
percentages and yes we were really happy
to have the opportunity to talk about
our research and technologies here and I
also would like to thank cui for is a
really nice presentation and very
interesting data and I learned a lot and
yeah I enjoyed the time thank you
I guess from my side up thank you
everyone for tuning into the
presentation today Thank You Felix Thank
You Michelle I guess it really comes
down to taking a look at your cell type
that you're interested in obviously some
will probably benefit a lot more from a
gentle sort some will benefit the same
and some will probably benefit less but
overall with our fairly robust cell type
you can see the results that we got
you
well thank you both again thank you for
your time today in your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor milk biotech
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to remind the
audience that they can submit questions
during the on-demand period and those
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand
and laboratory via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event until
next time goodbye